joining us now we have a member of the
Iowa Hawkeyes Tristan worse you do a
walk on man we're live on TV
oh this is perfect how are you I'm
fantastic oh are you oh it's great I'm
doing great we've had fun here at the
Scouting Combine I'm reading up on
Tristan worse I'm impressed you can do
it all state wrestling champ yes sir
aka don't mess with Tristan work what
weight class we're in I was heavy weight
and also a little shocked put a little
discus on top of it I'm always
fascinated by the field events how did
you realize that you had the skills to
to throw that disc is it the shotput
seems like it's a little bit he's at
discus I mean it's like a really heavy
frisbee there's got to be a fire down
there the field as far as you can yeah I
struggled with the discus you know when
I first started just I kept wanting to
just you know put a lot of power on it
like a goof on it whatever pulling
through someone's car she'll you know
when she'll don't know but we had tennis
and our practice throwing area there was
tennis courts at about 190 feet and my
junior year I started throwing it over
the fence so I'd have to wait till the
girls were done with tennis practice to
throw discs oh my goodness yeah you
don't want you don't want to throw a
disc over the fence when they're they're
playing good so what was more rewarding
for you the winning of wrestling match
or having a good showing with the
shotput of the disc I think when in the
wrestling state title was the most
rewarding thing because I put so much
work in it like I came into season way
and 322 pounds I got a Ida I had to cut
37 pounds to make it to make 285 that's
the that's the limit for heavyweight so
although all the hard work and I put in
the cutting that weight weight how much
weight did you have to lose 37 pounds oh
my goodness yeah so you know all that
all that dedication and discipline I put
into it you know was you know paid off
in the end of the state title so I think
that was the most rewarding when did you
realize that you were gonna have the
kind of football talent that you have to
put yourself in position to be drafted
you know I'm not sure when I when it's
when it clicked or when I realize it
because you know coming into college my
freshman year it's the NFL still felt
like like a dream like it was far away
you know that each year you know it
became more realistic and and it just
got closer and closer and then you know
eventually all of a sudden I had to make
a decision you know it's felt like it
went by so quick now I'm told that
you're the first true freshman to ever
start under Kirk Ferentz in Iowa which
is just remarkable you had to be shocked
because you had to know coming in no
true freshman has ever started so I'm
not even gonna think about starting all
of a sudden I'm starting went when did
you find out that you were gonna be the
guy to break that mold so we were
playing Iowa State as a second or third
game and we had a senior offensive
tackle is it like bugs actually with the
bills now he's you know he's kind of
like my like my big brother coming into
we were Locker buddies but we were
playing Iowa State and he ruptured his
Achilles and he went down I remember I
remember seeing him you know I was on
the sidelines seen him and like my
stomach just dropped to my feet because
I was like it was a type tie ballgame at
the point at that point and I'm like
like I'm I have to go in there you know
right now like I'm gonna lose this the
game was like I'm not you know I wasn't
ready but you know they they shuffled
some of the old linemen around but third
or fourth game of season and you know
next the next week I was I was in there
who's giving you best advice as you
prepare for everything you've been going
through the past few weeks and we'll go
through the next two months I think
coach Ference
you know gave me some of the best advice
you know especially for making the
decision to come to the next level and
he just told me said you know you've
done everything we've asked here and
more is that you've won the games that
you've earned just you you've given
yourself the you know the ability to
make this decision he said you know go
enjoy it he's like you only get to do
this one time listen you know that's
what I'm trying to do just you know have
a good time here and live it up when
you're around all these other offensive
linemen I mean is there camaraderie is
there kind of like I'm like what I could
take you I think I gotta thank you I
can't take you I'm not gonna go your new
direction how much of that goes on I
think the first the first day or two
it's kind of its kind of like that you
just you know you don't wanna step on
anybody's toes and you do
thing but then you know as you you know
as you settle in here god you start
talking to guys more you know meeting
new guys it's you know I think a little
bit of both and you probably come out of
it after being here for five days phone
numbers yeah and [ __ ]
texts you know guys you may be teammates
with guys you may be squaring off
against who's the guy when you get to
the NFL you're really looking forward to
lining up against him blocking oh that's
a good question
I think there's you know there's a
couple guys like miles Garrett like ever
seeing him when I was in when I was in
college still just thinking that he was
just he was a monster so it'd be cool if
we coul block him and you know JJ Watt
that's all you know he's been kind of
like a perennial you know perennial
player you know with me that I grew up
as a kid you know in Middleton high
school watching it weird though to be on
the brink of stepping onto the field
with guys you grew up watching onto it
as I said that I was thinking the same
thing
it's weird you know going from going
from watching them on TV you know in
middle school to now you know I'm about
to step on the field you know what those
same guys when did you have your big
growth spurt I had a couple I had a
couple growth spurts I think you know I
used to have girl like growing pains
like my mom I thought I was sick but I
wouldn't have a fever anything I would
just come home from practice or come
home for the day and like my my quads
would hurt really bad I'd be like a key
almost it felt like the flu you know
your body aches out of sleep for like 14
hours 15 hours and you know
another week would go by on my jeans
wouldn't fit they'd be too short just
stuff like that so I like I had like a
couple girls bred I don't think I had
one big one but I always thought I was
sick but it's just just growing pains
you told us about having to lose 37
pounds to get to the limit for the
heavyweight wrestling division do you
have to fight now to keep weight on to
be it you're playing weight or this is
it's no it's all natural it's just it's
just yeah I can I can eat you know what
I want but I have to watch it like so I
don't go over so I don't you overweight
but you know I don't gonna like fight to
keep weight on it's a lot of these guys
that play offensive line in the NFL when
they're done they they become bean pulse
there's nothing to them do you see that
in your future when you're done playing
football I don't know I don't think I
get too skinny but oh maybe maybe lose a
couple pounds
who was your favorite team growing up
you know I never had a favorite team
growing up I don't know why I liked
watching you know certain guys I loved
watching Ray Lewis I'd watched like his
highlight tapes on YouTube and I got to
like middle school I like Washington
Tyrone Smith the Cowboys left tackle
I like watching JJ Watt I never had a
favorite team growing up my mom's was
the Steelers my uncle's was the charges
so I kind of watched that my uncle was
kind of like he's like the father figure
so I would watch them with him but I
didn't I didn't personally have a
favorite team is there a guy that really
will have you just completely and
totally starstruck when you when you
it's like I'm on the field with this guy
and I can't believe it's happening
I like Tom Brady I think that you know a
lot of guys will probably say that just
because you know he's a lot of guys have
said Tom Brady yeah a lot of guys oh
yeah just because he's been in the
league for so long and you know it's we
we like grew like I actually grew up you
know what watching him I mean yeah it
was 20 years are you I just turned 21 in
January yeah you were in diapers yeah
the guys started playing in the NFL it's
amazing it's got to be amazing for him
there's got to be a point where he just
looks around and says I'm old enough I
am old enough to be these guys father
yeah so all right well a Tristan we wish
you all the best Tristan wharfs Iowa
offensive lineman first true freshman to
ever start for Kirk Ferentz a huge
accomplishment wish you all the best
moving forward in the NFL
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports